وما تحدث عنه بنت من تعزيز لقوات النيته
من البحر الاسود الى بحر البلطيق يحمل
علامات كثيره لموسكو فبالنسبه لروسيا
يعتبر البحر الاسود بمثاله بقاء وطنه لها
ومنطقه امنيه بالدرجه الاولى وذلك لحمايه
قواعدها العسكريه الموجوده في شبه جزيره
القرم خاصه الاسطول البحريه الموجود في
سبسطبول بالاضافه الى حمايه روابطها
الاقتصاديه والتجاريه كذلك مع الاسواق
الاوروبيه ويبقى جنوب اوروبا اكثر اعتمادا
على غازيها اما بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
في يمثل البحر الاسود الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه باعتباره واحده من اهم مناطق
توسع النيتروجت شرق او اوروبا خاصه في ظل
وجود ثلاث دول من اصل سته اعضاء في النيته
وهم تركيا وبغاريا ورومانيا كما ان بحر
البلطيق ايضا لا يقل اهميه عن البحر
الاسود بشكل اهميه وروسيا
خصوصا انه قد يصبح دائره نفود لحلف شمال
الاطلسي بما ان كل الدول المطله على هذا
البحر في حال انضمت السويد وفنلندا الى
الحلف ستصبح اعضاء فيه باستثناء روسيا
وعندها ستصبح موسكو في موقف اضعف بان فرص
الحلف لحصر لقوات البحريه الروسيه في
قواعدها ستصبح افضل مما هي عليه اصلا
فقتصاديا ستكون السفن الروسيه التي تغادر
مرفانتش العسكريه قرب سامبر سبورج عبر
خليجي في لندن من الشمال وكذلك من الجنوب
بدول اعضاء في النيته اما في حاله اندلاع
حرب فسيكون من الصعب على البحريه الروسيه
اجراء عمليات فوق سطح البحر وعندها ربما
يتعين عليها ان تتبنى موقفا دفاعيا بدلا
من الموقف الهجومي